welcome to this video and it's all a gas
yes my old friend Oleg us and I recently
won a game against him first one where
went to into total chaos mode earlier
early on and i'm wondering if i can
manage this somehow again let's see i
have to do something dynamic not not
another lame opening maybe some some
kind of kings in yen yeah come on let's
let's go for some non-symmetrical stuff
okay can I try to yeah let's do
something that that threatens and
threatens is his porn on a two I can
take now here I come on you have to
sacrifice a pawn now I can take with the
Queen it was silly of course I cannot
take on a 2-1 such a [ __ ] yeah that my
rookie is singing so I have to take now
and play this is terrible end game wow
wow okay jack so I just have to play
against the bishop pair here for no
compensation sometimes and sometimes
what you play is really really really
idiotic
now white is just much much better him
Ruby one and I'm just suffering in this
position even even a very simplistic
move like see if I if I probably not
rook F was my idea yeah he places and he
he likes this and super simplistic
continuations one reason is because he
always plays on time but this is not
such a case after Bishop b5 he really
has something but night eggs
everything's taken I have 94 then 95
Bishop b5
I cannot do that there should be five
rook c8 maybe this is maybe you can
somehow survived that
tags rope chains i have b8 covered just
barely
yeah Bishop g7 what I want to go to e7
anyway
yeah I cannot take take c5 but I have to
get my rooks connected I wonder I really
don't don't understand much of all that
this is so quick here I don't know I
have rugby aid this should really should
really keep things together it's the CF
pawn what is the basis upon this is this
a weakness also i mean check I can take
on f6 mm-hmm okay if I go back now it
takes rook c8 and that shouldn't be a
problem check you can play Bishop f4
just Bishop f4 what does silly blonde I
am what a silly blunder I could have
just played f6 yeah okay i'm an idiot
alack resigns he has chaos totally
totally played this wrong and I just
chatted play of 6 and nothing's
happening I mean okay i saw that Shack
but i wanted to play for win already
have this is this is clear i can do that
with no problem whatsoever that's this
is stupid this is just be this is just a
draw because we both have those
seventh-ranked things going on and one
of us will give a pet show this is
unavoidable something like this can have
five they can give a check if you can
step forward and and ultimately getting
them you cannot play for win here I like
this
that was stupid around here I don't know
but but this this is this is this is
definitely nothing knowing allowing me
to to do this so as I wanted to play for
a win here already and this was this was
wrong I mean mostly I just I just
checked I just blundered blundered to
this yeah it was a silly game anyway
this is Queen takes t3 is of course the
totally totally idiotic decision yeah
it's totally was completely forgetting
that he's attacking my rook so of course
I never take their otherwise giving my
bishop on g7 against the night I can
just play something when I have six or
something and he's maybe slightly better
here with the two bishops way okay
thanks for watching